this video is sponsored by curiosity
stream use the link in the description
to watch thousands of documentaries and
get access to our new streaming service
nebula at no extra cost in 2017 over 20
million people visited the most popular
theme park in the world Magic Kingdom at
Walt Disney World in Florida together
Disney parks including Disneyland
Anaheim Tokyo Paris and Hong Kong
attract a hundred and fifty million
annual visitors more than any other one
could argue however and I will there's
one even more popular IKEA with 460
million let me explain
we in the biz know there are many
definitions of theme park the academic
definition my definition and when you're
ready to really dive deep in the
literature you turn to the experts the
international association of amusement
parks and attractions who define theme
park as an amusement park that has
themed attractions be it food costumes
entertainment retail stores and/or rides
check close enough check check and check
shopping at IKEA is a full-day activity
you hop in the family van drive outside
the city drop your kids in the play area
max out your credit cards and then top
it off with some Swedish meatballs the
IKEA brand is as iconic and loved as
Disney Six Flags and Universal the only
slight problem is with the s and rides
IKEA has just won the unidirectional
pathway which guides you through the
store into the warehouse and the
restaurant the ride might be called
capitalism the theme of the park Sweden
although despite its colors names and
advertised philosophy IKEA is not
strictly speaking actually Swedish or
technically a company at all what are
the secrets behind ideas enormous global
success
although not nearly the same company it
is today ingvar comrade founded IKEA in
1943 as a traveling salesman selling
staples like matches pencils and watches
seven years later he began selling
furniture seeing the logistical
difficulty of shipping large items far
away in voir decided to flat pack the
furniture which also reduced the chance
of damage during transport the company
created a catalogue that customers could
browse through an order width from afar
the first showroom was built in 1953 in
the same small town followed by the
first of the company's iconic giant
warehouses in 1965 the business model
has more or less remained consistent
ever since rather than try to compete
with department stores and city centers
IKEA has always preferred large
multi-story buildings away from the
bustle with only a few exceptions like
in cramped Hong Kong with this far
cheaper real estate the company can
build equally giant attached parking
lots the average size of a store is
around 35,000 square meters or 370
thousand square feet with over 8,000
unique items inside the experience is
unlike any other customers are guided
through the store by a one-way path
which begins in the showroom flows into
the Market Hall where small items can be
picked up instantly and ends in the
warehouse where previously selected
items can be picked off the shelves and
then paid for at the register most
retailers design their stores to
maximize the time you spend inside
spreading out staples like bread milk
and bananas IKEA takes this approach to
the extreme by arranging its stores like
a transit line the company has total
control over the shopping experience and
forces you to look through all its
departments place towards the beginning
of the journey are usually its largest
drivers a profit bedroom and kitchen the
restaurant and kids play area not only
keep customers inside longer but also
communicate low prices and value which
spill over onto the brand as a whole the
average visit lasts a whole hour and a
half at many of its stores
and by one estimate 60% of items
purchased at IKEA are unplanned nudge
towards in other words by the store
psychology research also suggests we
attach more value to the things we help
make ourselves turning IKEA
self-assembly from a flaw to a feature
it also helps reduce manufacturing and
shipping costs another ingredient in the
IKEA formula low prices are its
self-proclaimed mission to quote
democratize furniture whatever it's true
motivation IKEA has remained inexpensive
despite its ubiquity the price of its
most popular chair for example has gone
down dramatically over time adjusted for
inflation the company reportedly sets a
target price for a product before
sending it off to its small team of
around 20 designers who work within
those constraints finally the warehouse
design eliminates the need for a large
staff which greatly reduces operating
expenses this low-cost image is so
important that before he died in 2018
the founder and CEO claimed only to fly
economy never say in luxury hotels and
use public transit staying true to the
company's values but perhaps even more
important than its psychology warehouse
design or low prices is IKEA 'he's
impenetrable brand as it began expanding
internationally first in Switzerland in
1973 then throughout Europe for the next
few decades it greatly emphasized its
swedishness from 2000 until 2009 the
company opened a hundred and fifty
stores more than a had in the past 50
years many in North America and Asia
today with over 200,000 employees and
433 stores IKEA is not only the largest
retailer of furniture but also the
world's largest consumer of wood period
its strategy has been to enter many
different markets each with only a small
number of stores at the most optimal
locations the US for example is its
second largest market by number of
stores despite having only 50 and 17
countries or territories have only one
the success of this approach is proof of
IKEA is global brand
while many companies enter a new market
by localizing their message and product
IKEA has succeeded by doing just the
opposite embracing its Swedish origins
the IKEA image is so strong around the
world that it can open a single store in
an entire country and still be instantly
recognized and loved from the minimal
functional design of its furniture to
their famously hard to pronounce names
IKEA is unmistakably Swedish it's bright
blue and yellow stores announce its
heritage from afar
beyond its visual design IKEA also
exports Scandinavian egalitarianism
employees at all levels are encouraged
to address one another by first names
and not titles corporate executives are
asked to participate in so-called
anti-bureaucratic weeks where they work
on store floors to experience daily
operations and empathize with their
colleagues not only is this association
with its home country good for the
company but it's also good for Sweden
who has encouraged and greatly benefited
from IKEA as positive reputation Swedish
embassies for example actively
participate in new store openings and
have even sponsored them financially
ironically despite all this IKEA is
legally more Dutch than Swedish the
company is actually owned by a Dutch
holding company whose profits end up in
a tax-exempt nonprofit also Dutch
Foundation who indirectly channels the
money through another Dutch foundation
with nearly the same name its
intellectual property meanwhile is owned
by a holding company called inter IKEA
this time registered in Luxembourg which
in turn is owned by a company of the
exact same name in the netherlands
antilles
who yes is also owned by a trust company
and that's a simplified explanation all
this legal fine print makes IKEA the
third largest charity in the world only
30% smaller than the Bill & Melinda
Gates Foundation
IKEA is certainly not unique in its
complicated legal structure but in
registering as a charitable foundation
it goes beyond the norms of most global
companies all this it claims is designed
to protect control of the company from
outside party
including in fairness the founders own
family critics though argue control is
only a secondary benefit after tax
avoidance legally physically and
financially IKEA is today more global
than Swedish and yet it has one of the
strongest most resilient brands in
history IKEA has come to embody a
certain rare kind of friendly capitalism
after all despite its size and
controversies who could hate a theme
park in its embrace of capitalism and
likeness to an amusement park IKEA is
slightly reminiscent of another unique
place on earth I'm making a documentary
about coming soon to nebula our new
streaming platform created by some of
your favorite youtubers from CGP grey to
Wendover productions rely floor and tier
zoo to make it affordable we've teamed
up with curiosity stream where you can
watch thousands of documentaries about
nature science technology even business
when you sign up for curiosity stream
with my link in the description for just
$19.99 a year you also get access to
nebula at no extra cost you'll not only
get to watch many of our videos ad free
but also exclusives in curiosity streams
entire catalog of documentaries and
you'll be supporting your favorite
creators all for the same cost of
curiosity stream alone thanks to
curiosity stream for sponsoring this
video and as always to you for watching